this video was brought to you by
Skillshare hi welcome to another
ColdFusion video Instagram is perhaps
the defining app of the last decade and
this makes sense because was actually
launched in 2010 unlike Facebook and
YouTube which were launched in the
previous decade while the term Instagram
influencer usually doesn't conjure up
the most stellar amount of respect
there's no denying that the app has had
a meaningful impact on society everyone
from Vladimir Putin to Ariana Grande and
Prince Harry has an account but it
obviously wasn't always this way how did
two nerds from Stanford University make
a billion dollar company worthy of
Royals and presidents how did Instagram
start in the first place how big is it
and what are some fun and interesting
facts about the company in this video
we'll find out
[Music]
so as you could probably guess the
impetus for what would become known as
Instagram was alcohol specifically
bourbon and whiskey we probably didn't
guess that but that was the original
purpose of the app in 2009 a 27 year old
man by the name of Kevin Systrom enjoyed
his fine bourbon and whiskey a lot so
much so that he coded an app called
bourbon the purpose of bourbon was so
that people could make plans check into
locations were those good drinks to be
had and share photos although a Stanford
University graduate Kevin had no prior
experience with computer science despite
his previous employment at Google while
working at another startup in his spare
time he learned to code on nights and
weekends at this point the Bourbon app
was just a small side hobby and Kevin
wouldn't have thought much about it at
the time but as with most things that
make a mark in the world is all about
being in the right place at the right
time and in this Kevin got lucky
[Music]
a crucial turning point came in March of
2010 when Kevin attended a party the
party was for a Silicon Valley startup
called hutch it was here that Kevin met
- venture capitalists he showed them the
prototype of the Bourbon app and they
were impressed they all decided to meet
for coffee to discuss the idea further
after the very first meeting Kevin took
a leap of faith and decided to quit his
job to focus on Bourbon within only just
two weeks he managed to raise $500,000
in seed funding from the venture
capitalists seemed out of the party with
this money he began assembling a group
and the first to join was Brazilian 25
year old Mike Krieger
Kevin had first met Mike during their
time at Stanford and they'd kept in
touch afterwards so it was a simple
decision for the two to work together so
now came the time to try and figure out
how to make this bourbon app a hit
although the app had check-in and
messaging features photo sharing turned
out to be the most popular feature also
there were many other similar apps on
the market for example Foursquare they
needed to focus on just one aspect of
the app and cut the rest it was at this
point that bourbon pivoted to become
more focused on photo sharing with likes
and comments at this point they would
change the name to Instagram a
combination of instant camera and
telegram
[Music]
as the week's wore on the small team
worked tirelessly to improve the photo
sharing capabilities in just eight weeks
of adjusting the application they
offered it to their friends for a beta
test they ended up fixing bugs and when
they were satisfied they decided to
launch it was Showtime Instagram was
launched in the 6th of October 2010 and
on that very same day it turned into the
top free photo sharing application
piling on 25,000 users this was a total
surprise and shortly after Kevin would
take to the forum Quora to voice his
excitement quote we never expected the
mind-boggling reaction that was seen we
went from truly a bunch of clients to
the number one free photography
application in only hours this growth
only continued and by mid-december they
had 1 million users you have to remember
that at this point they were just a
couple of young guys he is a quote from
Mike to highlight that one time I woke
up and there was an email saying that
the site went down and I was like who
fixed it Shane did you fix it
keV did you fix it no so apparently at
3:30 in the morning a somehow managed to
in a completely drunken state revive
Instagram that's how much was struggling
in those days are you success now have
you made it or is this just sort of the
beginnings is the opening stages rat
Kevin success for me was when my parents
started using Instagram I think that's
all I really needed the second you make
something that that your family loves
and uses I mean know how to use and know
how to use and use every day you know
but you know professionally obviously we
have a lot of growing to do I think well
15 million is great 150 million is
better and 500 million is even better so
you know we're at the beginning stages
of our company if we're gonna build a
100 year company we've been around for a
year so it's the tip of the iceberg
instagrams user base kept expanding and
investors soon took notice by early 2011
the come
was valued at 25 million dollars at this
time they added a motor staff Jack
Dorsey of Twitter tried to buy them out
but the 500 million dollar price tag
wasn't enough for co-founder Kevin by
March 2012 the applications user base
had swelled to 27 million in April
Facebook would buy them out for a
billion dollars
the key arrangement was that Instagram
would remain autonomous and that brings
us to the modern era we Instagram has
become ubiquitous could you ever have
dreamed being where you are today back
then no I think we started you know
knowing that we wanted to bring this out
to the world but this is kind of beyond
our wildest dreams when we were getting
started back then I remember looking at
Mike and being like I think we're on to
something
meanwhile he's stressing out trying to
keep the server's up and he's like maybe
so before we finish off what are some
interesting and fun facts about
Instagram well in 2020 it's becoming
less about influences and more about
businesses for instance 80% of user
accounts follow a business on Instagram
33% of the most viewed stories are from
businesses 200 million Instagram users
visit at least one business profile
every day the biggest brand on Instagram
is National Geographic with over 100
million followers this is followed by
Nike and then the NBA there's been some
criticism of the platform the negative
effects on body image among the young
are at the forefront as stated in my
facebook episode comparison is the
depletion of joy in other words when
people see the amount of likes that
someone has in their photos and they
compare themselves to them they end up
feeling miserable in an effort to combat
this in 2019 the company made the
decision to roll out a removal of likes
and certain posts now this next one's
interesting surprisingly eighty-nine
point five percent of all Instagram
photos are posted normally with no
Instagram filter added at all
Instagram is now estimated to be worth
100 billion dollars 37% of all adults in
the United States use the platform the
company is still fairly lean and only
employs 550 people around the world she
is a question
take a guess on what the most Instagram
food is you got it well it's Pizza the
most liked Instagram photo is an egg
with a white background the entire
account called world record egg was
created for the sole intention of
getting the world record for the most
number of likes which was formerly held
by Kylie Jenner in a nod towards
co-founder Brazil has the second largest
amount of Instagram users after the
United States okay
so we're pretty much at the end of the
video so what ended up happening to our
two founders well in 2018 both founders
would leave to pursue other projects
though Kevin Systrom is now billionaire
according to the Guardian he now enjoys
fine food golf skiing and holidays
meanwhile the other co-founder Mike
actively takes part in philanthropy so
what's the main takeaway from here what
can we learn if you are building
something and you're not sure in which
direction to go you have to focus on
strengths and try not to get attached to
ideas that you love but may not sell
well Kevin loved bourbon and whiskey and
thought that it was a neat idea to have
a place where people could form a
community around it but when he saw the
people were using the app primarily for
photo sharing he decided to pivot and
cut the rest and that was the decisive
move so I think everyone you know this
starts to start up you deal with
different scales but you should always
try to understand what you want your
startup to be you know if it hits 300
million active users right and I
remember talking with the folks really
early at Twitter and one guy
specifically and he was pitching like
someday you know celebrities and artists
are gonna use this to you community
with their fans and I remember thinking
yeah right there's no way that's gonna
happen but the key insight there was
they were thinking about it from day one
and for us we've always wanted to create
an open platform for visual media so the
ability to tune into anywhere in the
world at a moment's notice so if there's
something happening overseas we want you
to be able to tune in and experience
that through images so if there's a
protest overseas or if there's like
let's say the World Series is going on
or the World Cup right or the Tour de
France or some big event happening or
receives like the Tokyo earthquakes we
want you to be able to tune in to the
world and see things in a way that you
haven't been able to see them before if
you're thinking of building a business
on your own or another creative project
a great place to start is by learning a
new skill and Skillshare is a great way
to do that with Skillshare you can learn
valuable lessons to help you achieve
what you're setting out to do and you
can go at your own pace I did enjoy the
productivity course but Kevin Cisco he
goes over how to increase your
productivity in the digital age I
especially liked the part on the
Forgotten aspect of honing and
maintaining attention for instance your
emails and other notifications are a
to-do list dictated to you by someone
else so it's important to set those
aside and build a Productivity pipeline
that works for you
Skillshare is giving away two months
free premium membership to the first 500
people who clicked the link in the
description below
after that it's only around ten dollars
a month so I hope you learnt a thing or
two from that video and if you did feel
free to subscribe if you do want to
check out my Instagram it's here on the
screen now and I post some fun stuff on
there so anyway thanks for watching my
name is - gogo and you've been watching
cold fusion I'll see you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one
period anything
[Music]